[Music]
hi this is Chris gold with geeks on tour
and I'm using Picassa right now to
transfer some picture files from one USB
external hard drive to another and I
want to show you how I'm doing it first
to explain a little bit see I have this
a passport Drive which I've had for
quite sometime and I really like
it but it's only a 250 gbyte and notice
down here that it's getting kind of full
so I recently purchased a 500 gigabyte
Seagate
drive and it has all this space on it
what I need to do is transfer all the
photos I have thousands of photos on the
passport which I have designated as my P
drive and I want to move them to the
Seagate the S Drive first let me show
you what it looks like just in Windows
Explorer if I open up my passport
drive we'll see that I have a folder
called
pictures and in there there's going all
the way back to 2004 there's
20706 that's that is my notation for the
year 20 7 and the month of June then
there's May and April and I want to move
those to the
Seagate which I also have a pictures
folder and it goes back to 2001 I need
to get those the 2007 on here in Picassa
when you're in flat folder view that's
this little button here the normal view
I can't tell which Drive these are
on see there's 20712
20711 and I had it starts with
2076 which I know is on my passport
drive and I want to transfer it to the
Seagate drive I can tell all this though
if I just go into tree view now I can
see there's my P drive and here's all
the folders that are on it I want to
move these from the P
drive to the S Drive in the pictures see
I've moved a lot of them already there's
2006 but the ones
remaining are these here's how you do
it and and by the way why do I want to
do it in Picasso why don't I just drag
them over from Windows Explorer well
because a lot of these pictures have
have have
places people tags and they're in albums
Picassa has a lot of information
surrounding these pictures if I move
them outside of Picassa they'll get lost
to the Picassa information but if I use
Picassa to move them then all that
information stays
intact also Picassa is actually easier
to do this than Windows Explorer
step one select the folder that you want
to move rightclick choose move folder
now it I know that I'm moving a folder
from the P drive and I need to send it
to the S drive so there's the seate
drive and
pictures and I want this
20062 to be in the folder
2006 you can see right here it says move
folder to s pictures
okay and it is moving them first it
copies once the copy is complete then it
deletes it does it all for you and it
takes a few seconds depend this is three
it's moving 318 pictures now it's almost
done and I want you to watch over here
you will see the folder
disappear from its location in the P
drive and it will appear in its new
location there see it's gone from the P
drive now and if I come up here on the S
drive we'll see there is 201612 with 308
pictures I go back to Flat folder View
and I'll see2 20062 and in the flat
folder view we don't care what drive
it's on Picassa is handling all of that
now you might ask well can I move an
entire folder
structure it depends notice that this
folder here 2072 does have two other
folders under it I can move this top
level
folder to the other drive to the s
pictures ah now I need it to be
2007 and it
will move the
subfolders however I would not be able
to select this folder and have it move
all the ones underneath why because this
folder notice it just looks like a
manila folder it doesn't have have the
little picture thumbnail on it it can't
move that Picassa can only move folders
that have pictures inside the
folder if I put a picture in that folder
then I suppose I could move the whole
thing but I kind of like moving each
month individually it just gives me a
good secure feeling but I like the fact
that I can move this whole month and it
does move the folders that are inside
it and how about moving folders just
within a drive so on my S drive now
where I'm have where I'm keeping all of
these
pictures here the S drive I have come to
the conclusion that I do want them all
within a folder by year once again you
don't want to do this just using Windows
Explorer or you're you lose all the
extra Picassa information that goes
along with it so this Memorial Weekend
folder I look inside and I see that that
was Memorial weekend of
2002 so I want to move that Memorial
Weekend folder inside 2002 but what had
I said earlier that these this folder
doesn't actually have any pictures in it
so I'm going to try that little trick
and just put one picture directly into
the memorial weekend folder so I just I
went into Windows Explorer and I made
sure to put a picture into just that
Memorial Weekend folder now notice how
it has an icon in it now I can right
click on Memorial
Weekend move folder so I'm moving this
Memorial Weekend
folder into the s pictures
2002 and notice how fast that worked
because it wasn't physically copying
pictures from One drive to another it
was just moving the location on the disc
but because I did it with Picassa it's
going to keep hold of all the special
Picassa information
[Music]